هل أضرار الإغلاق أسوأ من
الفيروس
نفسه ، هذا هو سؤال الاستطلاع اليوم
وأنا مايكل سميركونديش في
فيلادلفيا ،
نحن على بعد 10 أيام من الانتخابات
، ونحن الآن في خضم موجة السقوط الطويلة
المخيفة
، فقد ضربت الولايات المتحدة
سجلت أمس أكبر عدد
من
الإصابات بـ covid19 في يوم واحد بأكثر من 83 ألفًا ، مما
حطم الرقم القياسي السابق للبلاد الذي
سجلته في يوليو بأكثر من ستة آلاف
بالإضافة إلى أكثر من
41 ألفًا ، وكان 19 مريضًا في
المستشفيات أمس
وحذر الخبراء من أن الصحيفة اليومية
ستزداد الأرقام سوءًا
قائلة إن الجناة في هذا الارتفاع في
الحالات الجديدة هم تفشي التواصل الاجتماعي في الأماكن المغلقة
في المدارس والإرهاق الوبائي
الذي يبدو وكأنه حالة من
الإغلاق الإضافي
، وفي الواقع
، يواجه ملايين الأوروبيين في نهاية هذا الأسبوع قيودًا أكثر صرامة بسبب فيروس كورونا ،
وبدأت ويلز في إغلاق لمدة أسبوعين
عادت مانشستر إنجلاند إلى
أعلى
مستويات القيود ، كما فرضت أيرلندا
مستوياتها الأكثر صرامة  من
القيود في أسابيع ،
لكن اقتراحًا كتبه مجموعة من
العلماء ذوي المؤهلات الجيدة يقول إن
هناك حلًا للتعب الوبائي ، يتيح اقتباس التعبيرات الوبائية
لأولئك الذين هم في الحد الأدنى من خطر
الموت أن يعيشوا حياتهم بشكل طبيعي
لبناء مناعة ضد الفيروس من
خلال العدوى الطبيعية
بينما يكون ذلك أفضل  حماية أولئك الذين هم في
أعلى
المخاطر تسمى الوثيقة إعلان بارينجتون العظيم
المؤلفون الأصليون هم ثلاثة
أطباء من ستانفورد هارفارد
وأكسفورد يدافعون عن ما يسمونه الحماية المركزة.
للسماح لأولئك المعرضين لحد أدنى
من خطر الموت أن يعيشوا حياتهم بشكل
طبيعي لبناء مناعة ضد
الفيروس من خلال العدوى الطبيعية
مع حماية أفضل لأولئك
الأكثر تعرضًا للخطر ،
فإن المبدأ الأساسي للبيان هو أن
عدم العودة إلى الحياة الطبيعية
يضر أكثر من
يؤدي إلى مشاكل صحية بدنية وعقلية طويلة الأمد
لذلك ينص الإعلان على أن
المطاعم والشركات الأخرى
يجب أن تفتح فنون الموسيقى والرياضة
والأنشطة الثقافية الأخرى يجب أن يستأنف
الأشخاص الذين هم أكثر عرضة للخطر ويمكنهم
المشاركة في إذا رغبوا في ذلك
بينما يتمتع المجتمع ككل
بالحماية الممنوحة للفئات الضعيفة من
قبل أولئك الذين قاموا ببناء
أثار نشر حصانة القطيع لإعلان بارينجتون العظيم
استجابة سريعة في
شكل شيء يسمى
مذكرة جون سنو لا ليست لعبة
العروش تشير إلى أن
هذا هو رأس القبعة لجون سنو الذي
كان عالم الأوبئة الأسطوري.
قد يعرض إعلان بارينجتون العظيم للخطر الأمريكيين الذين يعانون من
ظروف أساسية تعرضهم
لخطر كبير
من فيروس كوفيد 19 الحاد وينتج
ربما نصف مليون حالة وفاة
بالإضافة إلى التكلفة البشرية ، وهذا من
شأنه أن يؤثر على القوة العاملة
ككل وقدرة
أنظمة الرعاية الصحية الساحقة
لتوفير الرعاية الحادة والروتينية
علاوة على ذلك ، لا يوجد دليل
على وجود علاقات عامة دائمة  المناعة ضد مرض سارس
كوفيد 2 في
أعقاب العدوى الطبيعية ، فإن مثل هذه
الاستراتيجية لن تنهي جائحة كوفيد 19
ولكنها تؤدي إلى أوبئة متكررة كما
كان الحال مع العديد من
الأمراض المعدية
قبل ظهور التطعيم
، قال منسق الاستجابة
لفيروس كورونا الدكتورة ديبرا بيركس
هذا الكلام حول مكافحة هذا الأمر.
زيادة مفاجئة جديدة وخطيرة نشهدها الآن للاستماع إلى
هذا
الأمر لن يكون بسيطًا مثل إغلاق
الأماكن العامة لأن الأماكن العامة التي
يمكنك رؤيتها
كانت آمنة جدًا خلال الصيف
وربما تظل آمنة ،
وهذا شيء
حدث بالفعل في الثلاثة أو الأربعة الأخيرة  أسابيع
وما حدث في الأسابيع الثلاثة
إلى الأربعة الماضية ، فقد أصبح الجو أكثر برودة
وقام الناس بنقل تجمعاتهم الاجتماعية إلى
منازلهم
، ويبدو أن الأمر يبدو وكأن
التدابير الصحية التي تستهدف ، دعنا نقول أن الحانات أو
المطاعم على سبيل المثال
لن يكون لها تأثير إذا كان الناس
يجتمعون معًا  في منازلهم
بالداخل هو أن مدى خطورة
هذه المشكلة في الوقت
الحالي هو أمر خطير للغاية  قضية الذئب
لأننا نشهد انتشار المتفجرات في
جميع أنحاء البلاد وعلى عكس
ما كان عليه من قبل حيث كان لدينا عدد قليل من الأماكن التي كانت عبارة عن
نقاط ساخنة للفيروسات ، لدينا الآن نقاط ساخنة للفيروسات في
جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة ونعلم أيضًا
أن الدافع وراء هذه الزيادة الأخيرة
هو هذه التجمعات غير الرسمية
النبأ السار هنا هو أننا نعرف بالفعل
ما يتطلبه الأمر وقد قمنا
بعمل أفضل بكثير في الإعدادات الرسمية في
وسائل النقل العام في المطاعم
في الكثير من متاجر البقالة الأخرى
كمثال ، لقد قمنا بعمل أفضل كثيرًا في هذه
الإعدادات
ولكن  نحتاج الآن إلى التركيز على هذه
الإعدادات غير الرسمية ،
وأعتقد أن العديد من الأشخاص لديهم شكل من أشكال
التفكير السحري ،
نعتقد أن أحبائنا هم
أشخاص نثق في أنهم لا يمكن أن
يكونوا مصابين بفيروس كورونا
ولكن لا يوجد وجه لشخص لديه
غطاء 19 ونحن  بحاجة إلى
توخي نفس القدر من الحذر حول
أحبائنا ، وهذا يعني
أن تكون في الهواء الطلق لرؤيتهم قدر
الإمكان إذا كان هناك طقس سيئ في
إعادة الجدولة حتى يحين يوم أفضل
لرؤيتهم  الأبواب ، وإذا كنا في الداخل ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
الحد من هذا
الوقت وارتداء الأقنعة حتى لو كان ذلك مع
أشخاص نعرفهم ونحبهم ،
لذا ما هي الخيارات المتاحة أمام الناس
للتواصل الاجتماعي عندما لا يتعاون الطقس عندما يصبح الجو
باردًا
بالخارج  ليس من المفترض أن
أرى الناس شخصيًا
خلال هذه الأشهر القادمة من الشتاء
أه هنا في الولايات المتحدة
جيدًا نحن في شتاء صعب
للغاية وأعتقد أنه من المهم بالنسبة لنا أن
نضع في اعتبارنا أنه يتعين علينا تجاوز
هذا  في الشتاء
الذي قد تكون فيه الأمور مختلفة تمامًا بحلول الشتاء القادم ،
فمن المرجح أن يكون
لدينا لقاح ، وسيكون لدينا علاجات أخرى
ولكن علينا أن نجتاز الأشهر العديدة القادمة ،
لذلك من المهم حقًا أن نحاول
التواجد في الهواء الطلق قدر الإمكان
وهذا هو الأكثر أمانًا  طريقة للتواصل الاجتماعي في
الهواء الطلق بمسافة ستة أقدام على الأقل ،
يمكننا تجميعها باستخدام السخانات
ومحاولة بذل قصارى جهدنا مرة أخرى للتواجد في الهواء الطلق
إذا كان علينا التواجد في الداخل
، فهناك بعض الخيارات التي يمكنك من خلالها
تكوين جائحة وبائية  هل لديك عائلة أو
أشخاص آخرين تثق
بهم حقًا ويحد الجميع من
مخاطرهم مع إدراك أنه إذا كان هناك شخص واحد في هذا الكبسولة لديه مخاطر فهذا هو الخطر
الذي
سيتعرض لأي شخص آخر ، يمكنك أيضًا إذا
أراد الأشخاص حقًا الاجتماع معًا
خلال الإجازات
يمكن للجميع الحجر الصحي  لمدة 14 يومًا
ثم يتم اختبارهم ثم رؤية بعضهم
البعض في الداخل ،
لكن هذا صعب حقًا وغير
عملي بالنسبة لكثير من الأشخاص ولذا
أود حقًا أن أشجع الجميع على
محاولة التواجد في الهواء الطلق قدر الإمكان
وإدراك أنه ليس للأبد
ولكنه سيستمر  على مدى
الأشهر القليلة المقبلة ،
دعونا نناقش المشاكل في أوروبا
والاستسلام الواضح للفيروس من
قبل
الولايات المتحدة للمتحدثة
باسم منظمة الصحة العالمية
مارغريت هاريس التي أكره
أن أقول هذا الضيف المنتظم في هذا العرض
و  من الجيد أن تكون معك ، أتمنى
لو لم نضطر للتحدث معك كثيرًا كما
فعلنا على مدار
الأشهر التسعة الماضية ، لكن من الجيد جدًا أن تكون
معك وأنا
حقًا  يشرفني أنك قدمت
نفسك مرة أخرى في
هذا
الوقت المهم الذي قال فيه رئيس موظفي البيت الأبيض مارغريت
مارك ميدوز إن الولايات المتحدة
لن تكون قادرة على السيطرة على هذا الفيروس
حتى يحصل على لقاح ،
ردك مرحبًا بيكي
و  على الرغم من أنه من
دواعي سروري دائمًا أن أكون معك ومع مشاهديك
أيضًا ،
فإن استجابتنا هي لكل بلد
وهو وقت مخيف للغاية ، لكن
ردنا على كل بلد لم يفت الأوان أبدًا
حتى مع
البلدان التي شهدت تفشيًا هائلاً
كانت
وحدات العناية المركزة تفيض بالأشياء التي
تبدو
مروعة ، وكانوا قادرين على قلبها
عندما ظلوا في الأشياء التي
تعمل وهذا هو اختبار تتبع
التتبع الذي
يجمع المجتمع معًا
لفهم ما يحتاجون إلى القيام به
لعزل أنفسهم حقًا عندما "  لقد
كنت على اتصال
لتجنب الاتصال الوثيق بصدق
وتجنب الحشود وتجنب الأماكن سيئة التهوية
وارتداء القناع